ceret ramaphosa et syndicalistes à une
époque où les travailleurs noirs sont
exploitées sans limite
il préside le premier syndicat de
mineurs qui deviendra le plus puissant
du pays
redoutable négociateur il arrache les
concessions qui mène aux premières
élections libres du pays d'1 semaine de
la voile syndicalistes comme son dauphin
mais quand le parti lines et il lui
préfère thabo mbeki il quitte la
politique qui fait fortune rapidement
grâce au programme d'émancipation
économique qui donne des avantages au
noir il a beaucoup profité et de laisser
ce programme parce que maintenant
aujourd'hui il était à la tête de
plusieurs comme pas limited company
l'étoile de céret ramaphosa paris caen
34 mineurs sont abattus par la police
lors d'une grève à la mine de mary cana
en 2012 il est alors actionnaire est un
des directeurs de la mine
dans un courriel envoyé 24 heures avant
le massacre
il qualifie les grévistes de criminels
et réclame une intervention policière
le jour si malgré cela il devient vice
président aux côtés de jacob zuma
pendant cinq ans il consolide son
pouvoir sans trop porté ombrage au
président controversé
cela lui permet aujourd'hui de lui
succéder
on voit qu est ce qu il s est passé
l'opposant wade
le nouveau président doit maintenant
convaincre ni sud africaine qu'il est
capable de transformer la haine c'est le
parti de nelson mandela qui avait libéré
les noirs du régime raciste de
l'apartheid et toujours du gang rennais
par la corruption ici sophie langlois
radio canada montréal